[Musique]
aujourd'hui marque le début d'une
nouvelle aventure
la monture de la pratique sportive de
l'université paris 5 et pour cela nous
allons disposer très prochainement de ce
complexe sportif qui fait une superficie
de 13 hectares avec un bâti d'un hectare
avec quatre terrains de sport une zone
athlétique et qui répondra différentes
missions la première mission c'est
d'être un atout un atout pour la
formation des élèves une deuxième
mission qui relève de la vie de campus
ça va être une composante importante et
essentielle pour les élèves pour les
étudiants et puis quelque part à une
troisième mission qui relève de
l'attractivité
aujourd'hui on se doit de présenter si
on on prétend être universités échelle
mondiale d'avoir des installations
sportives de qualité et ce sera je
l'espère est très certainement le cas
avec ce complexe sportif
[Musique]
suit donc le directeur du service des
sports de l'université paris sud
c'est un service commun de l'université
qui doit bien entendu promouvoir une
politique sportive sur l'ensemble des
établissements de paris sud c'est donc
sur trois départements et neuf sites et
m
nous accueillons bien entendu ces
installations sur le plateau avec grande
joie puisque enfin nous disposons pour
des étudiants et des personnels qui
travaillent sur ce plateau
d'installations sportives de proximité
on sait que la proximité est un élément
essentiel si on souhaite que le plus
grand nombre
pratiquer une activité régulièrement
et donc on se réjouit de ces deux
premiers terrains qui rappelle bien
entendu l'arrivée d'autres terrains
puisque fin novembre prochain seront
livrés c'est tout ce que je viens
les deux terrains de rugby et le
complexe d'athlétisme
et puis pour la rentrée de septembre
2020 donc c'est bientôt le bâti avec de
nombreux gymnase au mur d'escaladé à gré
pour couverts de tennis et c'est évident
année on a été convoqué par l'université
de sacrées pour mettre au point
l'inauguration de la plaine des sports
étant responsable d'elle trois
management ayant un projet tutoré
d'organisation d'événements nous avons
pris en charge l'organisation
d'événements alors en concertation avec
l'université paris-x sacré ans il ya eu
des réunions vraiment très régulière
mais ce sont 25 étudiants qui ont
travaillé chaque semaine pour imaginer
cet événement avec les animations et
puis une concertation régulière avec
université paris sacré de la
communication c'est à la fois un projet
pédagogique qui mobilise les étudiants
et qui envoie la concrétisation
aujourd'hui
[Musique]